what's your analysis of current state of
Cinema it makes the 80s look [ __ ]
crazy we're living through another
repressive time when it comes to cinema
first really big repressive time was the
50s then we skipped the generation with
the 60s but then we got the 70s and then
the pendulum had to swing swing out
again right for the 80s and then this
pendulum swung the other way again for
the 90s I mean I lived through the 90s
making movies in the 90s I didn't
consider the 90s the 70s part two but it
was on retrospect it absolutely was now
the pendulum has has swung this way
again so I'm just waiting for the
pendulum to swing back too yeah me too
you know is there anything in the last
few years that you're like I've really
enjoyed this film I've seen a few things
but I didn't really want to talk about
new stuff okay all right because I don't
want to say anything bad about it me
about his movie because that's me like
attacking them almost like an ambush and
I'm not here to cheerlead for anybody
else's [ __ ] either hey [ __ ] you
directors can't talk about bad about
anybody else's stuff that's unfair and
so everything is about cheerling I'm
[ __ ] tired of cheerleading